hmm any Boston features not on this one
but me and Millie's will definitely do a
song we've been trying to find the time
his schedule and my schedule is like
crazy
Millie's is uh he's having a moment
right now he's incredible like I'm so
happy for him I met him in uh a South by
Southwest in like 2013 at the hotel
lobby he came up to me and was like I
watch your [__] on two dope boys and not
right now that's what's up I didn't
again a long journey yeah I'm so happy
to see like everybody like around the
world really catch on him too because
he's really so genuine and just so good
at what he does
it's like
people need to know about him who would
you put on the Boston hip or let's just
say Massachusetts because we if Jordan
Lucas is not from Boston who's on the
Mount Rushmore of of if you had to
exclude yourself because you're up there
but
[Music]
um
Massachusetts as a state Massachusetts
yes I would go like Legends too like
I'll put Guru of course I would do like
uh a lot of people don't know gurus from
Boston and Primos from Texas
um
that's a hard one man Ah that's a tough
one
would you let Benzino sniff it just take
a sniff sniff what the Mount Rushmore of
Boston or Massachusetts hip-hop would
you let him at least
would you at least like invite him to
the you gotta be
you got to wear your questions that's
crazy
that sounds crazy
snippet is crazy I mean like would you
let him sniff the list would you like
consider him
I mean the source was big you know made
man yeah of course
um yo The Source in itself the almighty
RSO you know yeah no like for sure like
yeah Benzino
he's definitely important to the culture
he's important yeah absolutely you're on
there
gurus on there
I don't I don't like this question
Joyner Lucas is on there yeah for sure
I'll let you I'll let you pick the
Rushmore and I'll just say give you
thumbs
can we go non-rappers yeah please static
selective static selector number
one okay
terminology terminology is up there yeah
like shout out to term man anybody I'm
forgetting
I love that I don't know it's like I'm
so
I gotta like tap more back into the
Boston scene because there's a lot of
cousin stizzes from there who was uh
Michael Christmas uh
I know way too much about what's the
what's the guy's name who's named after
beer that's oh is it Samuel Adams from
there Sammy Adams
see I never got into yesterday I missed
that whole [__]
but shout out to him
but you're up there yeah
are we considering koi from Boston is
she from Boston she has roots for sure
yeah she's from she's kind of like
Boston in Jersey
have you and her uh got to link up and
connect and yeah we're real cool like
outside of music too yeah she's she
seems like a great energy yeah I love
her she's super genuine and like I'm
super happy for her as well